I was taking 10,000 IU every day, all winter and still only reached 50. I'm now taking,
now at 45. So they're talking about their vitamin D level. And I'm currently not taking vitamin D
or K. So if you have that vitamin D, so that I said last week on the Zoom call, if you have that
vitamin D that you were taking before, then go back to taking it. If you don't, get the 80K
avail from us or get that model that one that you have was a good form of vitamin D too.
Vitamin D also take that and it would be good to take even 20,000 IU's if you were taking 10,000
every day through the winter and you only reached 50, you probably need more. So don't feel bad about
taking 20,000. I don't feel bad about anybody taking very high doses of vitamin D if they're
measuring it. So certainly won't want to be taking 20,000 IU's of vitamin D and you never measure it,
your vitamin D could be over 200. But if you're measuring it, it's still less than 100, you're not taking too much.